l'hiver comme d'habitude et à l écoute
des consommateurs martiniquais nous
proposons donc la viande de nos éleveurs
ns éleveurs professionnels martiniquais
dans un système de vente en drive pour
toujours respecter les barrières
sanitaires imposées par le gouvernement
les services sanitaires et donc nous
serons dans les communes de celle de
sainte luce du françois et de ces
pierres bien entendu la semaine
prochaine et l'eau à d'autres communes
on va vous tenez au courant mais c'est
pour justement assurer l'écoulement de
la production des éleveurs que nous
avons mis en place rapidement
ce système là donc c'est un système de
drive vous descendrez pas leur véhicule
pour respecter les barrières donc je
disais tout à l'heure et ceux qui seront
là pour vous fournir l'avion seront
également protégés pour vous protéger et
donc j'espère que la population par
répondrait favorablement à cette cette
proposition-là et bonbons gpi manger
local